يتم عرضه على أنه مستقبل
حياتنا عبر الإنترنت ، كيف تتعامل مع
أبي السيارة في الغرفة
حيث نلتقي بالعائلة التي تعيش
بعيدًا ، وقضاء بعض الوقت مع الأصدقاء
حتى في مكان لممارسة المهارات المنقذة للحياة
ولكن كل هذا الوقت عبر الإنترنت لديه بعض
المحترفين  قلق بشأن الطريقة التي
قد يؤثر بها المزيد من وقت الشاشة على
الأطفال والمراهقين الأصغر سنًا ،
فنحن بالتأكيد كأبوين
وكمجتمع في
نوع من عالم جديد شجاع إذا كنت
ستدرك كوري كروس طبيب أطفال في لوس
أنجلوس ، أعتقد أن
الأطفال على وجه الخصوص هم  يتعلمون من
مجتمعهم ويتعلمون من
الأشخاص من حولهم ويتعلمون
إشارات الوجه ويتعلمون التواصل البصري
هذه أشياء لا يمكنك الحصول عليها في
عالم افتراضي
وفقًا لدراسة بحثية أجريت عام 2018 ،
يشعر 65 بالمائة من الآباء بالقلق من أن أبنائهم المراهقين
يقضون أيضًا  الكثير من الوقت على الشاشات و 63 في
المائة قلقون من أن المراهقين
يفقدون القدرة على التواصل شخصيًا ،
حيث يتردد صدى القلق لدى
الطبيب النفسي
دكتوريا دانكلي.  مشاكل النوم
تتسبب في إلغاء التكييف الجسدي لكل هذه
المشكلات المتعلقة بوقت الشاشة ،
لذا فإن واحدًا من كل ثلاثة على الأقل لديه نوع من المشكلات في بعض
الأحيان لا يعمل فقط على
تقليله ، يعمل بشكل أفضل
لإزالة الشاشات فعليًا لمدة
ثلاثة إلى أربعة أسابيع  على الأقل وهذا
يسمح بإعادة ضبط الجهاز العصبي بالكامل
ولكن إذا لم تعمل أي شاشات مع
عائلتك وكانت نظارات الواقع الافتراضي هذه في
مستقبلك ، فهناك بعض الخطوات التي يمكنك اتخاذها
لإعداد حدود محددة للوقت عبر الإنترنت إذا كنت
ترغب في الحصول على  نظارات الواقع الافتراضي للأطفال أعتقد أنه
يجب عليك حقًا التأكد من
أنهم يستخدمونها لفترة زمنية محدودة جدًا ،
والحفاظ على التكنولوجيا المشتركة متوقفة عن
إعطاء طفلك أجهزتهم الخاصة
طالما كنت أعتقد أنهم يعرفون
أنه يمكنك استخدام جهاز iPad أو
يمكن للأخ أن يذهب إلى جهاز iPad هذا ويرى
ما يفعله نوعًا ما ينظم نفسه ذاتيًا
ما يحتاج إلى القيام به ويحافظ على
نشاط الأطفال لمدة ساعة على الأقل يوميًا ساعة
خارج ساعة من أشعة الشمس مثل ساعة
من القيام بالأشياء  مع أشخاص آخرين ،
أعتقد أن هذا في العالم الحقيقي وليس في
العالم الافتراضي